vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen als wir im
Februar nach Beginn des russischen
Angriffskrieges auf die Ukraine zu einer
Sondersitzung des Deutschen Bundestages
hier zusammengekommen sind haben wir uns
gegenseitig versprochen dass wir dazu
beitragen wollen dass die demokratische
Welt in dieser schwierigen Zeit zusammen
steht dass die Europäische Union
zusammensteht und dass die Demokratien
der Welt die Ukraine unterstützen wir
können jetzt nach zehn fürchterlichen
Monaten des Krieges und die Vorredner
bis auf den letzten aber die Vorredner
die anderen sind darauf eingegangen
welche fürchterliches leid die Menschen
in der Ukraine dieser Tage immer noch
erfahren wir können nach 10 Monaten
jetzt feststellen dass die Demokratien
der Welt zusammenstehen meine Damen und
Herren das ist ein ganz wichtiges Signal
die Demokratien der Welt stehen gegen
den russischen Aggressor zusammen liebe
Kollegen ein ganz wichtiges Signal auch
für die Menschen
und jetzt
tagt der EU-Rat der Bundeskanzler sie
sind heute auf dem Weg zum asiengipfel
ich komme darauf gleich noch einmal zu
sprechen aber insbesondere die
Europäische Union allein wegen der
geografischen Nähe spielt an dieser
Stelle eine ganz wichtige geopolitische
Rolle das was dort besprochen wird wie
beispielsweise der ölpreisdeckel um die
russischen Staatseinnahmen zu drosseln
ganz konkret oder die Ausweitung der
personenbezogenen Sanktionen finden ja
die breite Unterstützung die Sie hiermit
auf den Weg nehmen können und
gleichzeitig ist es wichtig dass was wir
geleistet haben und fortsetzen werden
ich denke an die finanziellen Hilfen für
die Ukraine die der Bundesfinanzminister
im Rahmen der G7 und der Europäischen
Union oder die justizhilfen die der
Bundesjustizminister auch im Rahmen der
G7 und der Europäischen Union und die
sie als Bundeskanzler im EU-Rat heute
noch was sprechen und nächsten Tagen
besprechen werden meine Damen und Herren
wir stehen obgleich sich dieses Volk
mitten im Krieg befindet in dauerndem
wir alle dauerndem Austausch mit den
Menschen und den
Führungspersönlichkeiten in der Ukraine
die Demokratien der Welt Deutschland die
Europäische Union sendet jeden Tag das
klare Signal an die Menschen der Ukraine
wir stehen an eurer Seite und
unterstützen euch wo immer es geht das
ist ein ganz wichtiges Signal diese
Woche liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und an der Stelle will ich
auch ganz kurz auf die Europäische Union
selbst zu sprechen kommen die Einführung
des rechtsstaatsmechanismus war ein ganz
großer Schritt nach vorne denn ja müssen
offen sagen auch als Europäer wir müssen
offen sagen dass hier und da auch die
Rechtsstaatlichkeit innerhalb der
eu-anfrage gestellt wird und ich will es
in aller Kleid unterstreichen Herr Orban
die Finanzhilfen für die Ukraine sind
keine Pokerchips in diesem Spiel meine
Damen und Herren wir wollen auch
Rechtsstaatlichkeit innerhalb der EU
durchsetzen
raten starke rechter innerhalb der
Europäischen Union und dann müssen wir
darüber hinausgehen der
Oppositionsführer Friedrich Merz hat es
angesprochen nämlich wie wir uns in der
Welt aufstellen auch als viertgrößte
Volkswirtschaft meine Damen und Herren
der Inflation reduction Act
beispielsweise der US-Regierung der
macht uns natürlich große Sorgen keine
Frage Herr Merz sie haben hier ganz
viele Fragen gestellt Fragen die der
Deutsche Bundestag in der letzten
Sitzungswoche längst beantwortet hat
über die Fragen Freihandel wir wollen
vorangehen mit Südamerika mehr Frisur
Chile Mexiko hat einen Neustart des Fan
mit den Vereinigten Staaten alles Punkte
Herr März ich weiß da ist immer noch
viel aufzuarbeiten auch in ihrer
politischen Geschichte offensichtlich
gegenüber der eigenen Parteien der
eigenen Regierungsverantwortung
alles Punkte die unter einer
unionsgeführten Bundesregierung nicht
möglich waren wir sind eine
freihandelsnation innerhalb Europas und
den Freihandel waren wir vorantreiben
liebe Kollegen Kollegen
und an der Stelle will ich auch das
Ansprechen der Bundeskanzler sprach es
anbezug auf den kommenden Samstag das
was wir in Deutschland machen konnten
als konkrete krisenantwort auf diesen
Angriffskrieg gerade im Bereich der
Energiepolitik wer hätte uns denn
ernsthaft zugetraut angesichts der
Tatsache dass Deutschland als
Langsamkeit als sein Land was hundertmal
nachgedacht hat was über ein Jahrzehnt
braucht um ein Flughafen in seiner
Hauptstadt zu bauen wer hätte uns denn
zugetraut dass wir innerhalb weniger
Monate ein lng-terminal in Deutschland
planen genehmigen bauen und am Samstag
in Betrieb nehmen werden meine Damen und
Herren das ist die Beschleunigung die
deutschland braucht das macht diese
Koalition liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und gleichzeitig schreiten wir bei den
modernisierungsprojekten weiter voran
ich denke an die digitalstrategie bei
planungsbeschleunigung sprach ich gerade
ich denke auch an die sozialstaatsreform
die wir machen mit dem Bürgergeld das
zum ersten Januar in Kraft treten wird
ich denke an Dinge wie die Absicherung
der gesetzlichen Rentenversicherung über
die aktienrente eine bafög-reform über
die handelsagenda Sprache ich gerade und
meine Damen und Herren zu den
Zukunftsprojekten dieser Koalition
gehört auch Deutschland endlich zu einem
modernen Einwanderungsland zu machen
weil liebe Kollegen Kollegen wir sind
weltoffen gleichzeitig machen wir das am
besten Interesse unseres Landes und
unserer Volkswirtschaft liebe Kollegen
diese Fortschritt diesen Fortschritt den
tragen wir nach Europa wir wollen
gemeinsam mit unserer europäischen
Partnern gerade in diesen harten
geopolitischen Zeiten zusammenarbeiten
und zu guter Letzt Herr Merz war ja viel
Kritik jedenfalls zu zwei Dritteln ihrer
Rede gegenüber dem Bundeskanzler und der
Bundesregierung dabei war wenn ich mir
die Zeitungsüberschriften der letzten
Monate anschaue im April Bundeswehr
Doppelpunkt März droht mit Blockade des
milliardenpakets Oktober Streit und
Bürgergeld CDU droht mit Blockade
November März droht mit Blockade der
Preis Bremsen das ist zurzeit keine
konstruktive Oppositionspolitik und
ehrlicherweise ist es nicht mal ist es
nicht mal eine Politik der alternativen
zu der Politik dieser Bundesregierung
meine Damen und die Sprachbilder die sie
es gerade getan haben in ihrer Rede Herr
märz die Sprachbilder von Bob der
Baumeister sind kein Beweis dafür dass
sie es an irgendeiner Stelle besser
könnte Liebe Kolle liebe Kollegen ganz
im Gegenteil ganz im Gegenteil
wir handeln noch diese Woche setzen wir
das Gesetz über die Strom- und
gaspreisgrenze in Kraft meine Damen und
Herren die zum ersten Januar gelten wird
niemand in Deutschland wird allein
gelassen aber natürlich wollen wir
gemeinsam Deutschland stärker machen in
der Zukunft ich würde mir wünschen und
das zum Schluss vielleicht als
Weihnachtsgruß in Richtung der Union ich
würde mir eine
Opposition wünschen die nicht nur
fordert preisdeckel bei Strom und Gas
ganz laut über Monate im Deutschen
Bundestag dagegen ist die nicht nur
fordern Freihandel und dann die
Bundesregierung fragt warum sie keinen
Freihandel macht obwohl wir es
beschlossen und erklärt haben schauen
Sie was wir machen und gehen Sie
gemeinsam mit ein gutes neues Jahr 2023
mit uns ich danke Ihnen
[Applaus]